[Music]
April is National minority health month
bringing attention to health disparities
and underserved populations when it
comes to Health Care Dr Audrey Cruz of
Intermountain Health is sponsors of this
segment is here to explain this further
welcome to the show thank you back it's
been a while since I've seen you yes
thank you for having me today of course
now obviously these disparities have
been around throughout history but since
covid things have Amplified right what
are you seeing out there absolutely so
we're seeing that our community is
becoming more and more diverse so Nevada
specifically but also Las Vegas we're
having a greater diverse population and
we're seeing that actually over the past
10 years the amount of Latino and
Hispanic population has grown over three
and a half percentage points so we're
almost at 30 percent in our community
and we're also seeing that there's a
huge disparity in terms of health care
when it comes to minorities out there if
the covid-19 pandemic taught us anything
it's that there is a huge disparity when
it comes to health care and yeah people
are you know being treated absolutely
now we there are also differences
between different minorities or between
different races I could say you know
when it comes to health so what do you
what kind of differences are there are
out there absolutely so what we see is
that various ethnic backgrounds and
minorities are susceptible to different
medical conditions and when it comes to
being a provider we have to be very
mindful about the culture that they come
from the access that they have to care
and also the languages that they speak
we have to be very mindful of all these
things so as a provider and as a part of
Intermountain our goal is to minimize
these disparities okay and how are you
guys doing that with Intermountain
Health with Intermountain we have so
many things that we are working on right
now a big thing is all is making sure
that our patients are feeling seen and
heard we want to make sure that in terms
of their visit we want to make sure that
their whole experience
they are feeling comfortable so in terms
of their preferred language we are
making interpreters available to them
and we are addressing not only them as
people but also their culture and their
traditions and their Lifestyles when it
comes to being a minority so it's very
important to keep all that stuff
absolutely and since I've worked so
closely with Intermountain Health I can
say that representation is also really
important they have so many diverse
doctors and and clinician people that
are working in the workplace as well yes
including you yes so it's great so we at
our clinics also we work with a various
background various group of people
um we come from not only you know I'm
Filipino I'm Asian so is my partner but
we also have Hispanic and Latino
assistants and we have you know
Caucasian assists we have pretty much a
whole we're at wide range of everyone is
represented everyone is represented yes
we want to make sure that everyone that
we see is feeling comfortable yeah
that's number one and I know even in
within the black community a lot of
people are scared to go to the doctor's
office so so that's so important to know
that they can feel comfortable in your
offices absolutely that's one of our
biggest goals and and one of our
fundamental values is to make sure that
we are increasing access to Care thank
you Dr Cruz now thank you to in around
health for sponsoring this segment for
more information all you got to do is
visit intermountainenvy.org